hi I'm rhyming right and i'm gerry
welcome two reasons to see where we give
you reasons to see and not to see the
incredible Burt Wonderstone so you and I
will hang out that we show so when a new
street magician stunt starts to make
their act looks stale world famous
magicians Burt Wonderstone at Anton
marvelton look to salvage their act and
their friendship by coming up with a new
incredible trick Ryan's consensus there
are enough reasons to see the incredible
Burt Wonderstone there are enough
reasons to see the incredible Burt
Wonderstone yeah you know it's it's
nothing special the movies certainly not
incredible um but it's it's a decent
Jerry's couldn't senses I think there
are some reasons to see the incredible
Burt Wonderstone there are some reasons
to see the incredible Burt Wonderstone
yeah i mean it's it's all right reason
to see number one steve carell steve
carell plays the incredible Burt
Wonderstone in this movie first off he's
not so incredible but he has enough
moments that made me laugh yeah one and
the thing is I'm sort of mixed on his
performance but I don't think it's
because of him I mean I have issues with
the tone in this movie and so like when
he is more ridiculous I like him less
and when he's a little more down to
earth in the in the role I like him a
lot and he has a character are in and
any cells you on the character arc to
Steve Carell knows how to bring heart
two characters like this especially ones
that are not so likable at first yeah i
know and i bought the arc it didn't feel
forced and i found myself really grown
to like this guy you know he came less
of an [ __ ] there's something about
when he's like totally into him so like
totally at the height of his Burt
Wonderstone eNOS or he thinks he's all
that it sort of felt like a character
playing a carrot felt a little forced
when he was being the [ __ ] Burt
Wonderstone but as
grows more into the obvious arc of
having more heart you know you'll see it
coming we're not really ruining anything
for you it's uh it's become it's better
he gets he does a better job throughout
reason to see number two steve buscemi
it's weird in the trailer they don't
really advertise Steve Buscemi's
character a lot but he's like one of the
main characters in this film yeah he
plays Anton marvelton uh Burt
Wonderstone partner and I love him well
you're also used to seeing Steve Buscemi
play all these like really shady yeah
really unsavory guys or really creepy
guys I call them gums really yeah and
it's nice I thought I just had a really
good time watching him play a really you
know you're fun sympathetic character
you know like you just want to give a
hug and hang out with them you know at
first I wasn't sure if I could buy him
because I was like a Steve Buscemi's
naturally creepy but he grew on me I
like the reason to see number three alan
arkin alan arkin is probably my favorite
character in this movie he's uh he's
really funny yeah it's that classic type
of alan arkin deadpan straightforward
type of humor yeah and he does another
great job in it he's he's the most
believable one yes he brings a lot of
just little nuances and stuff like that
he's really fun to watch and I normally
don't like you know older grumpy man
type of characters but he's leave as the
funniest one to me in the whole movie
and he has he brings a lot of charm to
this grumpy type of character too and
it's nice to explore his heart whenever
the the film allows those moments it's
like they didn't go like all the way
down the grumpy old guy forth like oh
it's funny cuz this old guys like he's
cranky snortin cocaine saying all silent
types of really obscene [ __ ] yeah it's
not that far down that rabbit hole of
like look all people doing stuff you
wouldn't expect old people to do like
he's just you know an actual cranky old
guy you would understand why he's had a
little cranky guy so so yeah he's
definitely a highlight in this film he's
the only person in this movie that I
felt allowed this movie to have a
of a magical touch reason to see number
four james gandolfini it's surprisingly
really fun yeah in the james gandolfini
plays the guy who owns the Las Vegas
hotel where Doug money yeah portis your
Steve Buscemi and Steve Carell Botha
performed an act and he's he's pretty
funny in the role I was surprised you
know he plays that character you know
that [ __ ] type of boss but he's more
later than that yeah you know I'm not
saying the writing later in but James
Gandolfini brought that charm you can
see why people might like him and you
can see why he's a successful
businessman but he's also got some sharp
deadpan humor that really made me laugh
a lot and he's got a lot of just these
little recurring jokes and stuff like
that that were really funny and every
time he was on screen again those
moments were a lot of fun reason to see
number five Olivia Wilde this is my
first Olivia Wilde movie oh wow
congratulations living wild I'm like I
don't know who that is did you find her
as hot as everyone says yeah been really
hot and I also I thought she did a good
job in this yeah but despite being just
go feel like him she doesn't really good
job in this film as well I've seen her
in more movies than just this and I
think she's really improving as an
actress so that's why I really felt that
she should be on this list of reasons to
see the movie because you know a lot of
these types of movies always had that
female role you know that be story the
possible romantic interest and she she's
more than just some be story in this
film me I liked how they wrote her
character to have more interest than
they usually write that type of
character they usually just keep them as
like an assistant or something yeah well
also the thing is that she's sort of
written as a joy where she's kind of the
she were going out she's not like one of
the we don't follow her around the whole
time but she's always kind of saying
what we're all thinking yeah because
she's always sort of calling Burt on his
ridiculous [ __ ] and stuff like that
and it's funny to watch them kind of
square off she's the person who kind of
keeps it a little bit more grounded
reality yeah she she helps ground it she
also brings a lot of that earnest you
know heart into it reason to see number
six funny moments yeah you know and I'm
recommending this movie because there
are enough funny moments it's not
hilarious but you know they're there as
throughout the whole film it's not like
it's funny in the beginning that it
stops me in Funny or it's only funny
here like throughout the film every
light five to ten minutes there's a
moment that'll make you laugh yeah
definitely I mean it was it was it
wasn't rapid fire but it was consistent
and and you know every few minutes I
found myself at very least chuckling in
something yeah like I don't know if I
got a good belly laugh out of anything
but I was always amused and it is enough
charm behind the humor as well and the
best moments are when the humor seems
more realistic than being over-the-top
like trying to be like will ferrell yeah
it well yeah it's better when these
actors who are more designed for more
realistic type of comedy provide more
that realism behind the performances and
and there's enough heart in this film to
to add to the funny moments as well and
the heart didn't feel forced which was
nice that sounds good you want to move
on to the reasons not to so reasons not
to see reasons not to see the tone yeah
the tone it is is sort of my main issue
with this film because it didn't seem
like it fully knew what kind of comedy I
wanted to be yeah because half of it is
grounded in something close to reality
and then the other half is really broad
and absurd and like I like absurd humor
a lot but it it doesn't work right when
it's when the world isn't set up for
that it's more of its realistic moments
the realistic humor that really nails it
better so the tone is uneven because
they're like sex jokes in it that I
didn't feel worked for this film because
it sort of has a family film type of
feel to it but it's rina watch a family
film with sex jokes in it reason not to
see number two doesn't live up to its
potential you know it has this absurd
world it has a great world it's a great
setup actually you know like to explore
the magician world between like last
his show and then like the street type
of magician performers yeah but it with
its execution it plays it surprisingly
safe for a film that could have been if
they if they were more committed to its
absurdity if they're more come if they
realize what world they had to play with
I felt that it could have been a much
better movie you know that's why it's a
decent movie to me just only because
there's so much more it could have done
yeah but it doesn't go to the lengths
that it could have gone to this is one
of those prime examples where would have
been really cool to have more actual
metrics yeah and it's sad to see a movie
that's about magic so heavily but yet
the film doesn't feel magical and you
know that's uh that's a big letdown to
me actually so that's a reason not to
see we'll move on to a split the split
decisions what decisions Jim Carrey I
think we're calling this a split
decision not because we're in
disagreement about like I thought Jim
Carrey was funny and he didn't it's like
we're both sweat on how he felt about
Jim Carrey yeah you know there are some
people who really think he does a
fantastic job in this but then I saw
this movie and I I don't recall one time
he made me laugh yeah yeah a little bit
it's weird cuz cuz he comes on he's not
even that big of a character in a set he
didn't feel like a big character to me
because all he really does is come in
every ten minutes and then do something
that upsets Burt Wonderstone and then he
leaves again yeah you know something
violent to himself but that's about as
far as it goes I get the joke like he's
not really doing magic he's just doing
like violence tough to himself most of
the time yeah it's that extreme magic
worth like is this even really magic if
you're just gonna lay holes for a week
like it would have been cool to see him
do more magic you know I this the
trailer of this film emphasizes the
competition between Steve Carell and Jim
Carrey a lot yet it doesn't really feel
like there's much of a competition
really don't feel that intensity to be
like yeah Burt Wonderstone be Jim Carrey
yeah it's just kind of like it's just
that annoying everybody yeah it's just
like Nelson Muntz came by and said haha
then left yeah you know it's they almost
has competition
and then not even really especially in
the finale you know we're not going to
give away the finale but the app finale
is that's when they should have done
like the ultimate competition between
Burt Wonderstone Jim Carrey he's good on
the role you I don't I think you're not
supposed to like him and I yeah and it
didn't like him yeah so I am I'm really
mixed feelings about Jim Carrey he
didn't really make me laugh but I guess
he does a good job the role alright guys
so I'll give you a quick recap of the
reasons to see and not to see the
incredible Burt Wonderstone Jerry you
want to take it away with the reasons to
see I will take it away reason to see
number one with steve carell reason to
see number two esteem shimmy Steve's
residency number three was alan arkin
reason to see number four was james
gandolfini number five was Olivia Wilde
and number six was the film's funny
moments and the reasons not to see would
have to be the tone and it doesn't live
up to its potential and what decision
this week Jim Carrey alright guys thanks
for watching our video if you want to go
ahead and comment below and tell us your
reasons to see or not to see the
incredible Burt Wonderstone please go
ahead and do so and if you want to check
out my straight to the point review of
the incredible Burt Wonderstone go ahead
and click on this link right here and if
you want to check out more reasons to
see reviews click this link right here
and if you want to get updated every
time a new video or a new review is out
every week go ahead and subscribe grip
though subscribe it's um it's a magical
review show we got going on here
abracadabra see this box you click the
button and it changes your whole email
and your YouTube account man it's crazy
does it well you just got another such
thing you subscribe to but yeah do it do
it man the Internet's fence and then
like magic much like magic it'll tell
you without you even having to do
anything when new videos are oh yeah and
like and how how does that work yeah
right how does email and all that makes
sense don't even ask cuz a good magician
will never reveal the see ya
no the internet work who mended the
internet Jeff Internet
you